Thank you, I'm a software develop per at bark
box in New York City where we develop apps
to keep dogs happy and healthy.
This is a picture of my dog, SmallTalk and
me, this is a picture of a picture of me eating
noodles, and this is a picture of SmallTalk
eating noodles, now that you know all about
me, let's talk about type coercion in JavaScript
I've been programming predominantly with JavaScript
for the past couple of years and I've gotten
pretty familiar with many of it's quirks,
one of it's quirks being type coercion, I
hope to provide a better understanding how
JavaScript converts between types and the
various situations in which it performs type
coercion.
Butt let's back up, let's talk about type
conversion in general. Wikipedia says that
type conversion, otherwise known as typecasting
or type coercion, is implicitly or explicitly
changing an entity of one data type into another.
So, what does that mean more simply? That's
taking a type for example an Int and converting
it the another type, a string. So, how does
JavaScript handle type conversion? JavaScript
is dynamically typed, as many of you know,
which means that variable types are determined
during script execution at Runtime.
So, here, type conversion can happen in two
ways. They can be explicitly specified by
the developer in the code, like for example,
directly calling Parsint which converts a
string to an integer or to string or implicitly
performed with type JavaScript. This type
of conversion is typically referred to as
type coercion, and type coercion is what we're
focusing on today. So, why do I have to learn
this? Honestly, it's very much built into
the language. It kind of comes with the territory
of JavaScript being die familiarically type
language.
The example type coercion is happening even
with something as simple as a basic "if" statement.
In this example here we know that if successful
value.length will return an integer that would
be the length of the value. However, the if
statement here is expecting a pool Leon condition
integer is not a Boolean. It converts it into
a Boolean in order to evaluate this expression.
Type expression can also offer more flexibility
and can be convenient at times like when you're
dealing with user input. And finally, get
to know your language better, it's always
important to understand what's happening underneath
the hood. So let's build some foundational
knowledge.
Let's talk about converting types. There are
two categories of types in JavaScript, you
have the simple types, which are numbers,
strings, Boolean, the values true and false
Nul will and undefined everything else is
an October, arrays, functions, regular expressions
and of course objects. In the next three slides
I'm going to try to define JavaScript typically
implicitly converts between different types
and use this knowledge for the remainder of
the talk. So how does JavaScript convert from
simple types to numbers, for strings there's
an attempt to parse the string to a number,
otherwise it returns an NaN or not a number.
Boolean is converted to one, false is cob
verdicted to positive zero. ‑‑ converted
to positive zero. Nu is converted to positive
zero and undefined is converted to not a number.
What about converting simple types to Boolean,
numbers are converted to true unless the value
is positive zero, negative zero or not a number
these are converted to false, and strings
converted to true unless the value is the
empty string which is converted to false,
Nul and undefined are both converted to false.
And and finally what about objects, how are
objects converted. When converting objects
to numbers and strineses JavaScript will try
to convert the objects‑‑ by implicitly
calling value of on the object. Or if value
of isn't defined or didn't return a primitive
type when called it will try to call two string
on the object inside. Converting objects to
Booleans is a bit simpler, they're converted
to true. So let's take these guidelines and
apply them to a few situations and let's start
with conditional statements first.
But let's quickly just make sure we're all
on the same page about truth and falsey values
in JTPA. Some examples of values that translate
to true is 123, the string "smallTalk" the
Boolean true, and objects. Some examples of
values that evaluate to false in JTPA are
the integer 0, not a number, the empty string,
the Boolean fault, null and of course undefined.
The conditional statements if for wile and
do while aliening to valuablee valuable conditions,
if it does not return a Boolean openerands
are implicitly converted to ball listens,
if example in this example Var equals document.get
element by ID SmallTalk, it looks for an element
with a particular ID in a DOM. Wit return
an object if it finds an element or it will
return null, if an object is returned the
if statement will implicitly return it to
true, null will return if implicitly converted
to false.
So switch statements are a bit special here,
similar to an if statement the expected valuable
Boolean condition, unlike the if, when evaluating
the switch cases statements no type coercion
is performed, so, in the previous if statement,
values coerce to true or false depending on
whether or not get element by I D returns
an object or not. Here value will not be coerce
true or false it will be treated as it's original
type, because of that it will never satisfy
case statement true since neither object nor
null are equal to the Boolean true and it
will instead enter the default case. Logical
operators, which are of course, and, and or.
Let the conditional operators convert to Booleans
depending on the context, unlike conditional
operators the operator is returned not the
Boolean value. So incidentally this can be
great for setting default values. In this
example, Var value is equal to zero or apple,
value is‑‑ sorry the or operator is
looking from left to right for the first true
open aerator to undere return, it's converted
to false, apple is converted to true and some
value is set to the string apple. T
omohiro Matsuyamacal operators, which are,
of course, the addition and subtraction sign,
multiplication and division sign and of course
the module operator. Opener ands are converted
to numbers, except for dates, which for some
reason are converted to string, Var values
equal the true plus null plus 5, true is converted
to one, null converted to zero and one + the
zero + five is six, value set to six: The
interesting operator the take a look at here
is the addition sign. The addition sign is
overload in the JavaScript, so that means
not only can it do addition between two numbers
it can do string Concotenati no, when one
is a string and the other opener and isn't,
the other opener and is converted to a string.
In this first clam example Var example is
converted to the string maul talk + 2, the
value set to SmallTalk + 2 is converted to
a string 2 and then Concatenated this is happening
left to run, 1 + 2 is add together because
JavaScript isn't aware of the string that
follows, then 1 + 2 equal to 3 is Concatenated
to 3 small talk. Relational operator time.
Those are greater than,less than, greater
than equal to, or less than and equal to.
Similar to the mathematical operator, opener
ands are converted to numberser here even
dates are converted to numbers an exception
is strings are compared via lex graphical
string comparison. Compared sequentially,
similar to how you oridance e words in a dictionary.
Keep in mind here any comparison involving
not a number will evaluate to false. In this
example, Var values equal to false, less than
the string 1, 2, 3, false is converted to
0, the string 1, 2, 3 is converted to 123,
and value set to true. Because, of course,
0 is less than 123. Now for the more Meaty
stuff, equality operator. Equality means in
JTPA‑‑ values are considered equal if
they are identical Boolean values, true is
equal to true, note call to false, if they're
identical strings, the string ABC is equal
to string ABC but not to say ABCD. There are
also considered equal if they're numerically
equivalent numbers 1 is equal to is 1, positive
0 is equal to negative 0 in this case.
Values are considered equal if they're the
same object. And, again, not-a-number is special
here, it's not equal to anything, including
itself. And as you all probably know there
are two sets of equality open pert or in JavaScript‑‑
the double equal op perai to and triple. Dot
double equal operator‑‑ if it determines
that the types are different. The double equals
operator follows what's known as the abstracts
equality comparison algorithm, a series of
22 steps used to determine the quality.
When the expression meets one of the step
conditions, JavaScript will return true or
false accordingly, otherwise if it reaches
the end of the series, it will return false.
We'll get into a bit more detail about how
type coercions are performed here, but first
let's walk through an example. So, Var value
is equal to null greater than or equal to
zero. Using the knowledge that we obtained
about relational operators this seems pretty
straightforward, the relational operator implicitly
converts to numbers, so null will be converted
to zero, and, of course, steer row is greater
than or equal to zero, so values set to true.
But let's look at another example, offed Var
value is equal to null, bobble call zero.
This returns false. What the hell?! How does
that make sense? Everything we've learned
so far implies that null will be converted
to zero here. But in short null is treating
ad in a special way by a double equals operator,
it only corresponds to undefined. There is
only one of the many strange cases that involve
the double equal operator. All due to and
can be explained by following the abstract
equality algorithm.
So, the abstract quality algorithm is defined
really quite clearly in the if‑‑ language
specification, I don't want to bore you with
all 22 steps, by I did want to walk through
what happens after JavaScript has determined
that the two types are different and attempts
to type course, which are incidentally steps
14‑22 in the algorithm. Null equals undefined
and if one opener and is a string and the
other opener and is a number the string will
be implicitly converted to a number. If one
of the opener and s is a Boolean, the Boolean
will be implicitly converted to a number,
if one of the operands the string or the number
and the other operand is an object, the object
will implicitly convert to a primitive. So
the triple equals open aerator behaves similar
to to the double equals open aerator except
no type coercion is done, it uses straight
equality comparison algorithm, nearly identical
to the first thirteen steps comparison algorithm.
But leaves out all the bits related type coercion,
types must be the same initially in order
to be considered equal. Otherwise the triple
equals operator returns false.
Since there are no unexpected type coercions
being done, when using the triple equals operator‑‑
equals results and it can be mump safer. So
the tool I cam across preparing for my talk
was this JavaScript equality table. A graphically
displays the results of comparisons using
the double qualms and triple equals operator,
so green means expression of evaluator to
true, white means expression evaluator false.
Of so ininclusion‑‑ as amentioned earlier
it can be dangerous to use the double equal
operator if you're not sure what you're doing,
try to perform explicit type conversion when
you're able to do so, so that was from my
earlier slide, calls parse in or two string.
And use the JavaScript console and ECMA script
language resources this was provide foundational
knowledge, but it's of course missing detail,
the ECMA script language goes into this in
depth. It's not too terrible love a read,
surprisingly. Thanks, guys, come chat with
me later if you'd like the discuss any of
this or tell me about your dogs (Applause)
ask cool, so we're early, you guys get the
jump on the lunch queue. So ... head on out,
you can thank her for having a zero lunch
queue.